hey guys it is the twenty fourth of July
today my name is Jess McDonald and
you're watching games but news first up
today to kick games have been tweeting
out suggested Bioshock images but won't
confirm what it all means just yet even
though the series creator irrational
games shut down 2k tweeted a picture of
an Yves garden advertisement from the
original game with the hashtag discuss
another tweet then followed zing Oh what
could this mean the Eve's got an ad
appears in the original game and
bioshock tues multiplayer mode smart
money seems to be on a remastered
edition of the original bioshock game
and potentially the sequel but let me
know if you think otherwise for the
first time in forever we've got a story
about Knights of the Old Republic three
so you better believe I'm talking about
it much like the crash bandicoot talk of
earlier this week obsidian entertainment
had said they recognized plenty of
people would love a third installment
into the star wars RPG it's been a full
ten years since coat or two but
obsidians josh soya says there are a lot
of people in the studio who would be
keen to work on a sequel the trouble
with a third game coming to fruition now
is that EA have signed a multi-year deal
to produce Star Wars games so it would
need to come through them and Lucasfilm
have declared All Star Wars content
including games need to be canonical
just as the last ps4 update landed in
our laps and we all made jokes about
stability sony of announce that update
1.75 is coming next week there's been
some disappointment over Sony's lack of
new features in updates for their
next-gen console compared to the xbox
one's monthly updates now though 1.75 is
going to add support for 3d blu-ray
movies again we'd like to ask any member
of the public who has news on what the
heck happened to update 1.73 to come
forward finally game devs may not be
doing as badly as you think with the
average u.s. salary sitting at a Thai
dat three grand the 2013 figure was
presented in gamma sutras annual salary
survey which takes into account to more
than 4,000 debs in 2012 it was a tad
higher at eighty four thousand three
37 but there's a pretty clear indication
that male devs are still better off than
their female counterparts women are
earning an average of eighty-six percent
of what men do on the whole though
interestingly this depends on the field
where female designers earn ninety-four
percent of what their male counterparts
do women working in the audio field
mega-mega sixty-eight percent compared
to male salaries outside of the game dev
industry the average female salary in
general remains at seventy-seven percent
of what their male counterparts turn
fourteen percent of survey respondents
said they were laid off this year while
sixty percent saw a salary increase
unsurprisingly the big money is in
business and management which pays
around 100 grand while the worst is half
that salary in quality assurance aka
game testing as for indie devs those
working solo made about 12 grand while
ones who worked on a team averaged about
50 and your question of the day is if
you had to choose would you prefer a new
bioshock game or new Knights of the Old
Republic game if you like conventions
and live stream goodness and it's well
worth you knowing that San Diego
comic-con is a thing that's happening
this week we will be having a two-hour
live show from Thursday through to
saturday starting at 4pm PT each day so
visit gamespot to get stuck into that
for all the info and whatnot that is it
for me today but do you remember that
tomorrow I'll have the very best gaming
stories of the entire week so be sure to
check back then